if you're looking for lucrative
investment this might be the place to
find it start the bidding yet 35 million
dollars 36 million already served in
2010 said we sold this material painting
for 70 million dollars four times the
price it was sold for back in nineteen
ninety nine that's a 52 million dollar
profit in just 11 years now another
motive liana world is up for auction at
Sotheby's in Paris the portrait of
Pollock song is expected to sell for at
least seven million dollars this work
has all the qualities which are sought
after by collectors it is in pristine
condition it is presented for the first
time on the marketa the out market seems
to be in fine health the CEO of sub is
Frances despite political tensions
version buyers are still present along
with Chinese and Latin Americans global
sales grew seven point five percent last
year to more than 65 billion dollars but
that doesn't mean bagging and your
painting is a sure thing when it comes
to making money you are first to buy art
and to collect if you are passionate if
you want this painting of Picasso or
painting of malignant and then in
addition it could be a good investment
but in this order not the other way
patients as well as provenance is key
someone buys this painting they may have
to wait a few years to make a
significant profit conan conan bloomberg
paris
you